“Blonde bombshell” is often used to describe
an exciting, dynamic, sexy woman with blonde
hair, particularly blonde celebrity sex symbols.
The expression seems to have come from, or
at least was popularized by, a movie and originally
referred to a specific blonde bombshell.
In 1933, the platinum blonde Jean Harlow was
one of the most popular actresses in Hollywood.
That year, Harlow starred in a movie called
Bombshell (at the time “bombshell” in
American slang was already being used to refer
to incredibly attractive, flamboyant women,
with the first documented case of this in
1860).
One of the advertising lines for the film
was ==
When the film was released in England, they
even renamed it “Blonde Bombshell” as
it was thought in England that the original
title sounded like a war film, which the movie
is decidedly not.
(It’s actually about an actress who gets
fed up with being a sex symbol and just wants
to lead a normal life).
While it seems probable that this wasn’t
the first time someone out there uttered the
words “blonde bombshell” (those two words
fitting together so nicely), this does appear
to be the first documented instance of it
with, of course, the first actress to be labeled
such being the lovely Jean Harlow.
Within a decade, “blonde bombshell” was
being bandied about referring to several different
famous women and, of course, today has spread
to mean any particularly attractive blonde
woman (and in a few instances, such as Charles
Borck, men).
Bonus Jean Harlow Facts:
• Both beautiful blonde bombshells Jean
Harlow and Marilyn Monroe did their last movies
with Clark Gable as a co-star (Saratoga for
Harlow and The Misfits for Monroe).
• Harlow was not just partially responsible
for the “Blonde Bombshell” moniker, but
also propelled the platinum blonde craze that
swept the nation.
Howard Hughes even set up Platinum Blonde
Clubs and at one point offered $10,000 (about
$123K today) to anyone who could come up with
a hair dye that exactly matched Harlow’s
supposedly natural “platinum blonde” hair
color.
• Jean Harlow’s real name was Harlean
Carpenter.
“Jean Harlow” was actually her mother’s
name (Jean Poe Harlow), which she decided
to use as her stage name.
• Harlow’s mother and father did not get
along, the marriage having been arranged despite
the objections of the bride.
The couple finally divorced in 1922 and Harlow’s
mother attempted to become an actress, but
was considered too old at 34 and was forced
to move back to Kansas in order for Harlow’s
wealthy grandfather to continue to support
them.
This was a major event in Jean Harlow’s
life as when she returned to Kansas with her
mother, her grandfather sent her to Camp Cha-Ton-Ka
where she contracted scarlet fever.
Obviously she didn’t die of this, so why
is this such a momentous occasion in her life?
Because many speculate that it was her bout
with scarlet fever that ultimately caused
the problem that would result in her death
at 26 on June 7, 1937.
Specifically, her death was probably due to
kidney failure, resulting in “uremic poisoning”
(the buildup of various toxins in the blood
causing a variety of complications).
She also gained significant water weight during
this time as you might expect from kidney
failure.
The official cause of death recorded at the
time was “cerebral edema” (basically,
excess water in the brain).
For about a month Harlow’s illness was misdiagnosed
as the flu then a gall bladder infection,
even though she’d been showing signs of
the real problem for over a year.
It wasn’t until on June 6, the day before
her death, that she checked back into the
hospital after having vision problems that
the doctor realized that her illness was something
more severe.
• Harlow’s mother was a Christian Scientist
(who most members of don’t believe in receiving
medical care, but rather relying on healing
via highly structured prayer from “practitioners”
and an individual believing what is wrong
with them is simply an illusion of “mortal
mind”).
Because of this, after Harlow’s death a
myth rose up that Harlow only died because
her mother refused to allow her to be treated
by doctors.
This isn’t the case at all.
Her mother only refused one doctor access
to Harlow, MGM’s doctor who later claimed
that Harlow’s mother refused to allow doctors
to see her due to her religious beliefs.
Other doctors were allowed to treat the ailing
Harlow.
• Unfortunately for Harlow, medical science
had not yet advanced enough to be able to
do anything about her condition at the time,
even had she been correctly diagnosed.
The first successful kidney transplant didn’t
occur until 1954, and, even then, the lack
of a good method to suppress a patient’s
immune system so that their body wouldn’t
reject the transplanted organ was extremely
problematic.
Initial efforts towards this end included
bombarding patients with large amounts of
X-ray radiation, which was partially successful,
but also tended to have the side effect of
killing the patient.
It wasn’t until around another decade that
tissue typing and immunosuppressent drugs
started to be developed and used so that successful
transplants started to become somewhat common.
Even then, it wasn’t until around the 1980s
when the kidney transplant success rate started
to be extremely high (about an 85% success
rate in the 1980s).
• Harlow got married at the age of 16 to
20 year old Charles McGrew, who received a
large inheritance when he turned 21.
This allowed the couple to move to Beverly
Hills, where seemingly boredom (neither of
the couple worked) and Harlow’s friend,
aspiring actress Rosalie Roy, helped inspire
her to get into acting, first taking roles
as an extra, and progressively landing larger
roles until her big break when she stared
in Howard Hughe’s Hell’s Angels, which
debuted about a year after Harlow divorced
her husband in 1929.
• Harlow’s second husband, Paul Bern,
killed himself by shooting himself in the
head just two months after marrying Harlow.
At the time, there was significant speculation
that Harlow had actually murdered him, but
an apparent suicide note in Bern’s handwriting
was found stating: “Dearest Dear, Unfortunately
this is the only way to make good the frightful
wrong I have done you and to wipe out my abject
humiliation, I Love you.
Paul…
You understand that last night was only a
comedy.”
It was also speculated that Bern may have
been murdered by his estranged and supposedly
mentally ill common law wife, Dorothy Millette
(who he had supported through her mental illness
before she was released a couple years before
Bern’s death and pronounced mentally fit).
He continued to support her after her release
and visited her on occasion apparently remaining
on friendly terms.
Millette was also found dead just a couple
days after Bern, apparently from suicide (found
drowned after taking a trip on the Delta King
steam boat and supposedly jumping off, but
there were no witnesses.)
Depending on which conspiracy theorist is
talking, this either proves that she killed
Bern (killing herself out of guilt) or proves
that Harlow did it or had it done (perhaps
using her connections with her former lover
and notorious mobster Abner Zwillman).
Or, you know, Bern might have really just
killed himself as all the evidence points
to and the somewhat already mentally unstable
Millette may have fallen into a deep depression
upon hearing about Bern’s death and killed
herself over it.
• Jean Harlow was the godmother of mobster
Benjamin Bugsy Siegel’s daughter, Millicent
Siegel.
• Harlow’s third marriage was arranged
by MGM in order to avoid a scandal.
Shortly after Bern’s death, Harlow began
having an affair with famed boxer Max Baer,
who was married at the time, though already
separated from his wife.
When Baer’s wife finally officially filed
for divorce, she listed Harlow as one of the
reasons (because of the affair).
MGM hoped that by having Harlow marry Harold
Rosson, this would help quell the scandal
occurring so soon after the previous scandal
of Bern’s suicide.
It worked and once the media storm died down
about a half a year later, Rosson and Harlow
ended their arranged marriage.